'RE UNDERWAY.
PITTSBURGH IN THE HOME BLACK.
KRIS WRAPAROUND ATTEMPT BY
YAMAMOTO.
LOOSE PUCK.
A COUPLE WHACKS AT IT.
Y AT FULL SPEED.
SEAN: EVANDER KANE BREAKING IN.
SHOTINTO THE
SLOT.
OFF OF DRAISAITL.
THE SAVE MADE BYAND EDMONTON L'O
THE  TURNOVER, AND A GREAT
PUCK .
CENTERIN LIFTED
BY BRYAN RUST.
A SHOT WENT BY EV ASSISTED ON TL
TONIGHT.
A CHANCE FOR BOUCHARD AFTER VIDY
WASMATHESON HITS THE POST.
HE GETS PITTSBURGH ON THE BOARD.
[GOAL HORNS]
HE WAS CHALLENGING THE MATHESON
SHOT.
CARTER G CARTER.
EVANDERA OF ICE.
JUST THE PERFECT TIMING, HAD TOK
IN MIDAIR.
SEAN: YAMAMOTO ABLE TO 3-1 LEADE
AND SPACE AND HE GETS THE STICK
FREE, ABLE TO PUT THIS REBOUND
FARTHREE-ON-TWO THE OTHER WAY.
THIS ISRTER IS A LITTLE BIT LATS
IS JUST AN UNBELIEVABLEY CUP AS.
SEAN: THE PUCK IN THE RUST TRYIT
BACK.
THERE IS THE SHOTENGED.
CASSIE:TO
THE OFFSIDE.
NO GOAL.
SEAN: 2-2SIXTH OF THE YEAR FOR .
FOURTH LINE KULAK, A
LITTLE PASS OUT.
PUT SIT